[Music]
I will tell you
that I don't think Donald Trump needs to
be president I think I need to be
president I think that's good for the
country but I will beat him fair and
square I do not believe Donald Trump
should be prevented from being president
of the United States by any Court I
think he should be prevented from being
president of the United States by the
voters of this country all those judges
were Democrats of course they are I mean
this is and and you know I mean you
don't even get me started I could go on
the whole hour about how this is
unconstitutional assault I think the
precedent that a court could just take
somebody off the ballot without even any
type of criminal conviction or anything
like that uh I think that that is not
the way uh the laws intended to be
enforced I agreed with a lot of his
policies I had a good working
relationship with him but rightly or
wrongly chaos follows
him Republican presidential candidates
reacting to this big news out of
Colorado barring Donald Trump from the
ballot in the state's primary as a
jockey for votes 26 days to go until
Iowa caucus day the former president has
opened up a big lead over his GOP Rivals
67% support in the new quinc University
poll out today Nikki Haley also getting
a bump now tied with Florida Governor
Ronda santis there at 11% Nikki Haley
rep Republican presidential candidate
joining me now former ambassador to the
UN and former South Carolina governor
Ambassador Governor good to have you
with us thank you very much uh for
joining us today do you think think that
this is a an injustice this Colorado
decision uh and you think it's wrongly
decided by this
court thank you Martha I think this is
you know it goes back to our country
being in disarray the idea that judges
are going to take it upon themselves to
decide who can and can't be on the
ballot is truly Unthinkable and I think
the people of Colorado should be furious
I am going to defeat Donald Trump on my
own
I don't need a judge to go take him off
the ballot I don't think he should be
president I think I should be president
I think our country would do a lot
better if I was but we should have this
race fair and square with him on the
ballot just like everybody else and the
idea that we would go and say just
because these liberal justices don't
like him they want to take him off the
ballot that's not a democracy that's not
who we are that's not what we need to do
so you were talking on the campaign
Trail in Iowa about how chaos follows
the former president everywhere he goes
and I was just talking with you may have
heard the tail end of it while you were
waiting um for our discussion from Carl
Rove and you know he's saying look the
chaos is fueling Trump's numbers people
people seem to want that they seem to
want a rail against the system that is
trying to shut him down so what what do
you say to that when voters say look you
know what I know how he feels I get a
bad deal too and and I'm going to stick
up for him what do you say to
them that's that's not what they're
saying I mean when I we've done over 140
Town Halls now and you know even talking
about this situation I think what
they're saying is Americans are tired
they don't want the chaos anymore they
don't want this to happen and you know
look I have said I think president Trump
was the right president at the right
time I do agree with a lot of his
policies but rightly or wrongly and
again this is wrong what Colorado did
chaos does follow him and we can't have
a country in disarray and a world on
fire and go through four more years of
chaos we won't survive it you don't
defeat Democrat chaos with Republican
chaos and it's time that we get things
on track but people feel so harshly
about him or so much the other way that
that's why you see in general election
head to heads Trump and Biden are within
the margin of eror I think the Wall
Street Journal said he was up four
points I defeat Biden by 17 points in
that same poll that would be a mandate
that's a mandate not just for for the
presidency for the house for the senate
for Governor's races but it's a mandate
to get our economy back on track and pay
down this debt it's a mandate to get our
kids reading again and make sure we get
back to the basics in school it's a
mandate to close our border and make
sure there's no excuses it's a mandate
for Law and Order in this country and
it's a mandate for a strong America that
we can be proud of Americans want it we
can feel it on the ground the energy is
there they don't want the chaos my
Approach is different no drama no
Vendetta no whining it's all about
results and I think that's what the
American people want so what about when
it comes to some of the serious
situations that we're facing at our
Southern border and also in the Red Sea
which is obviously that that's a battle
with Iran which is quite clear um for
the Border first I I find it really
amazing I I talked to two of our top
senators in Washington this week and you
listen to what's coming out of the White
House there there's not a solution based
here's what we need to do or the
president needs to employ this executive
order tomorrow um if you were sitting
there right now watching this if you if
you you know the inauguration was today
what's the what would you do how would
you manage this thing because people are
so so infuriated about
it they should be infuriated we just had
our highly day highest daily total
12,600 IL illegal immigrants in one day
that is such a dereliction of Duty I
would go and pull them into a room and
say you're not going home for theid
holay until we fix this it is
Unthinkable that Congress is going home
when we've got that National Security
risk sitting on our border America is
acting like it's September 10th we
better remember what September 12th felt
like because it only takes one we need
to secure our border once in for all we
need to defund Sanctuary cities we need
to put 25,000 more border patrol and Ice
agents on the ground and let them do
their job we need to go back to the
remain of Mexico policy so that no one
steps foot on our us soil and instead of
catching release we need to go to catch
and Deport no excuses the American
people have had enough of this well you
heard uh the former president say that
he would be a dictator only on day one
he said he would shut the border down is
that something that would be in your
power as president and how would you do
it well I think the way I approached it
just what I said is how we would do it
you don't let anybody come across the
border that hasn't been vetted it's not
about being a dictator it's about
understanding that we are a country of
laws the second you stop being a country
of laws you give up everything that this
country was founded on and that's why
all these illegal immigrants that have
come over they all have to go back they
all have to be deported because every
time you let someone stay they call
their family members and it signals for
the rest of them to come you're
incentivizing people right now to make
that Trek we've got to start making
examples of these people by deporting
them back that's the only way to get
this to stop Biden gave half a million
Venezuelans temporary protective status
that's half a million Social Security
numbers that's half a million driver
licenses I know what happens when I was
at the United Nations that is the the
signal that they go tell their families
come on over they're going to let you
through this has got to end and
Republicans and Democrats owe it to the
people of America to put a stop to this
border and they should not go home right
now they should get in a room and Biden
should be ashamed of himself you can't
have a president who doesn't watch out
for the safety of the American people he
owes the American people an answer as to
why he won't do what's needed to close
off the Border thank you very much uh
Governor Nikki Haley 26 days to go we
hope to have lots of conversations with
you between now and then it's a big
moment that is coming in Iowa as we kick
all of this off thank you very much
Governor Merry Christmas if I don't see
you in the next few days but um we'll
look forward to seeing you after
that go to nikey.com Merry Christmas hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else